the Howard Jensen and Danny kenjemi for
the concept and creation and to John
Frazier for the development of the 60
and 100 foot rain bars the academy
presents them with a technical
Achievement Award come on up
[Applause]
oh there it is looks pretty big riding
there
you can't screw that up
my name is John Frazier and I'm a
special effects supervisor for motion
picture industry this year will mark my
58th year in the film business
my wife has said to me that uh
when I die she's going to have me
cremated and put me in an hourglass and
keep me working
but I'd like to thank my lovely wife for
54 years for standing by me and for
writing this speech
I'd like to mention our son Eric who was
here tonight
right there
Eric is a fourth generation filmmaker
so we're trying to keep it in the family
for a long time
when he was growing up as a small boy he
I asked him what he wanted to do in life
and he says I want to be a chick magnet
and uh well that worked all right for
her for a while
but then he had to pay the bills
so he became a special effects artist
and his mom and I are especially proud
of him and and glad he's carrying on a
family tradition
I'd like to thank the academy for
acknowledging my contribution to the
film industry for the development of the
60 and 100 foot rain bar it has been
used as the industrial standard for
producing the range for 40 years
I'd like to give an acknowledgment to
all the scitec and the CGI artists that
are here tonight that's you guys
most scripts would still be sitting on a
shelf someplace if it wasn't for you
guys
all films that are mostly generate the
revenue generated comes from films that
are Laden with CGI and rain
the the Advent of CGI has generated
thousands of jobs while making some
amazing films
I'd like to give thanks to Howard to
Mary Howard Richard edlin and Brooke
Boyles for all their hard work putting
on the scitec awards over the years I'd
like to think that and I'd also like to
thank the sign girl
she never gets a thank you all right
come on come on come on
I mean there's that's responsibility
right there if she sneezes she could
start world war three
but
I'd also like to thank Danny and Howard
for their concept little did they know
it would be the first step in creating
what we now call the rain bar
the rain in the film is a dramatic
device that is used to show mood emotion
as well as tension
the special effects crew is responsible
for bringing the rain to the screen
it is also the job to make the director
happy it is director's job to make the
audience happy
with the success of the rain bar and
being able to adjust the size of the
range off by using the correct rain
heads in most cases we've been able to
discontinue the rain stand
I appreciate your acknowledgment of my
contributions to the motion picture
industry
knowing the parties that have received
this award in the past and their
achievements is truly a humbling
experience for me
Danny
thank you John
my name is Danica Jimmy and special
effects supervisor this month this month
marked spark this month starts the 47th
year in the industry
44 years ago
I was involved in creating building a
piece of equipment that would be
developed into what we now known in the
industry standard called the rain bar
I want to thank the academy for this
award
it's very much appreciated I also want
to thank my wife
Lori putting up with me with long hours
on production and my twins Colton
Cassidy for being the drive to keeping
this to keep me going in this business
thank you very much
[Applause]